liebe freundinnen und freunde meine
damen und herren
herzlichen dank für das großartige
willkommen hier in apolda herzlichen
dank es ist ein wunderbarer blick hier
heute abend in dieser gut gefüllte halle
ich freue mich dass sie in so großer
zahl zu diesem 28 aschermittwoch in
thüringen gekommen sind und ich freue
mich mit ihnen das apolda und thüringen
ein so großes medienecho findet und ein
so hohes interesse bei den
vertreterinnen und vertretern der
deutschen presse
sie werden morgen alle in der zeitung
lesen können apolda das ist deutschland
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
und sie werden in großer objektivität
sehen wie die medien berichten wie es
wirklich um die stimmung in unserem land
bestellt ist
das ist hier nicht berlin kreuzberg das
ist mitten in deutschland und so sieht
deutschland auf
[Applaus]
ich freue mich dass sie mike mohring so
herzlich begrüßt haben und dass sie ihn
heute auch so herzlich auf zeit
verabschiedet haben
[Applaus]
lieber mike und es war für mich völlig
klar dass sich gerade in der zeit jetzt
nach thüringen kommen und mit ihnen
darüber sprechen wie es jetzt
weitergehen soll
es ist einfach in einfachen zeiten
zusammen zu kommen aber die wirkliche
cdu und die bürgerliche gesellschaft
unseres landes
die zeigt sich erst dann wenn es mal
schwierig ist und deswegen freue ich
mich dass sie in so großer zahl heute
abend hergekommen sind auch und gerade
die ihr zu ehren lieber mike mohring
[Applaus]
die landtagswahlen im letzten jahr und
ich bin einige male hier in thüringen
gewesen
noch am freitag vor dem wahltermin war
in der außergewöhnlich schwierige wahl
und trotz des abschneidens der cdu dass
wir uns besser vorgestellt hätten wir
eine bewertung beurteilung bemerkung
erlaubt und das wollen nicht immer nur
alle gerne hören
auch in den medien alle anwesenden
ausgenommen aber draußen in den medien
wird das nicht so gerne geschrieben und
gesendet
deswegen müssen wir vielleicht einmal
daran erinnern bodo ramelow hat diese
landtagswahl am 27 oktober 2009 10
verloren er hat die mehrheit nicht mehr
locker
und ich habe es offen gestanden in der
zeit in der ich politisch denken kann
noch nicht erlebt dass jemand der eine
wahl verloren hat
mit einem solchen anspruch antritt
wieder ministerpräsident zu werden
obwohl er mit seiner bisherigen
koalition im eigenen landtag keine
mehrheit mehr hat
wo kommen wir da eigentlich hin wenn wir
das stillschweigend akzeptieren dass so
etwas selbstverständlich hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und stellen sie sich mal einen kurzen
augenblick vor
es wäre einer von uns gewesen der mit
einem solchen wahlergebnis am abend um
18 uhr nach hause gegangen wäre die
gesamte deutsche öffentlichkeit hätte
selbstverständlich erwartet dass dieser
kandidat dieser ministerpräsident am tag
danach sein amt zur verfügung stellt
warum eigentlich nicht in thüringen ja
ich weiß meine damen und herren liebe
freundinnen und freundlich weist dieser
ministerpräsident hat über die grenzen
seiner eigenen partei heraus ein
bestimmtes ansehen auch in den reihen
der union in den bürgerlichen kreisen
gibt es zustimmung zu ihnen ja das ist
so
mit verlaub auch mit respekt das in
ordnung so aber es gibt doch in einer
solchen situation und das sage ich hier
ganz offen auch wenn der ein oder andere
in der cdu vielleicht anderer meinung
ist wenn die cdu die christlich
demokratische union vor den wahlen
gesagt hat dass sie zur wahl eines
ministerpräsidenten von der linkspartei
nicht zur verfügung steht
dann muss dieses wort auch nach der wahl
gelten wenn es nicht geht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es hätte überhaupt keine notwendigkeit
gegeben
im landtag von thüringen wenige tage
wochen nach der landtagswahl eine
ministerpräsidenten-wahl anzusetzen
ich komme aus nordrhein-westfalen
landrätin kennt das land auch gut wir
haben im jahr 2010 an der landtagswahl
in nordrhein-westfalen gehabt weil er
die damalige ministerpräsidentin in
einer ähnlichen lage wie hier in
thüringen keine mehrheit mehr hatte im
landtag
es gab auch keine andere mehrheit also
hat diese ministerpräsidentin über zwei
jahre ohne mehrheit im landtag eine
minderheitsregierung geführt
das geht auch und das wäre auch in
thüringen möglich gewesen der
eigentliche fehler der das ganze
ausgelöst hat hier und ich komme auf
unsere fehler gleich noch zu sprechen
aber der auslöser war die arroganz die
überheblichkeit zu sagen ich stelle mich
hier zur wahl und erwartet dass andere
mit stimmen obwohl sie vorher in
wahlkampf anders gesagt haben das war
der eigentliche auslöser
und die befreundete das trotzdem nicht
darüber hinweg dass auch die christlich
demokratische union ihr fehler gemacht
hat staatsbürgerliche verantwortung ist
das eine aber die ist nicht beschränkt
auf das eigene bundesland oder ramelow
ist ja nicht vom himmel gefallen und ins
bett der linkspartei zufällig
hineingeraten sondern ist aus dem westen
gekommen und bewusst und vorsätzlich in
diese partei eingetreten und diese
partei meine damen und herren ist
unverändert lesen sie das
grundsatzprogramm der linkspartei eine
partei die mit großen teilen dieser
republik mit unserer offenen
gesellschaft mit unserer
marktwirtschaftlichen ordnung mit der
art und weise wie die demokratie für
richtig halten wie wir dieses land sehen
mit privateigentum mit freien
unternehmer mit diesem land nichts am
hut hat die wollen eine andere republik
und dann gibt es dann gibt es eine
gruppe die nennt sich marx 21
eine gruppe von trotzkisten teile dieser
partei allesamt vom verfassungsschutz
unter beobachtung
mitten in dieser partei zu hause und da
zieht sich eine gerade linie von denen
die da im biedermann daherkommen bis hin
zu den krawallen und ausschreitungen in
leipzig connewitz und da gibt es eine
landtagsabgeordnete im sächsischen
landtag gestellt diesen chaoten noch das
vom steuerzahler bezahlte
landtagswahlkreis büro zur verfügung
damit die ihre logistik vorbereiten
können meine damen und herren mit so
einer partei hat die christlich
demokratische union in deutschland
nichts zu tun das sind die feinde
unserer demokratie und deswegen gibt es
hier eine klare haltung und jetzt wird
die cdu dafür dass sie dies nicht klar
genug gesagt hat dass dies nicht
vorbereitet war
dass dies nicht stringent durch gehalten
wurde
bei allem respekt für die
meinungsunterschiede für das ringen um
den richtigen weg aber dafür wird die
cdu in thüringen jetzt ja vermutlich bei
der nächsten landtagswahl einen preis zu
zahlen haben dann ist das so so ist
demokratie
aber liebe freunde zu uns gehört die
christlich demokratischen union dass wir
auch denjenigen die mal eine falsche
einschätzung gehabt haben fehler gemacht
haben dass wir die nicht einfach
stehenlassen und fallen lassen sondern
dass wir sagen okay da haben wir alle
zusammen nicht das richtige eingeschätzt
nicht das richtige getan und jetzt
halten wir trotzdem zusammen und wenn
die nächste wahl ansteht dann ist nicht
nur die thüringische cdu dann ist die
gesamte zeit
die eu in deutschland aufgefordert hier
herzukommen nach thüringen und dafür zu
sorgen dass die cdu so stark wie möglich
wird bei der nächsten landtagswahl und
dann gucken wir nicht nach rückwärts
sondern gucken wir nach vorn und sorgen
dafür dass dieses land wieder eine
starke cdu gekommen
das ist unser zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl
und so arbeiten wir zusammen
meine damen und herren liebe freundinnen
und freunde ich hätte mir in dem
zusammenhang gewünschten ich will das
auch hier ganz offen ansprechen dass sie
auf dem parteitag in leipzig als wir
diesen beschluss gefasst haben etwas
stärker differenziert hätten
es wäre ganz gut gewesen denn wir unser
verhalten gegenüber der linkspartei
auch von den papieren die wir da
geschrieben haben getrennt hätten von
unserem verhalten für afd
ja es gibt viele gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen linkspartei und afd
eine ganze menge aber es gibt auch eine
ganze reihe von erheblichen
unterschieden und es gibt vor allen
dingen ein thema in diesem land und
darüber müssen wir miteinander reden das
ist der ausufernde und immer
gefährlicher werdenden rechtsextremismus
in diesem land meine damen und herren es
gibt in den letzten jahren
es gibt in den letzten jahren rund 200
mordopfer in deutschland durch rechten
extremismus und terror
wir haben dieses problem unterschätzt
und wenn wir es jetzt richtig erkennen
dann müssen gerade wir in der mitte der
politischen parteien in der mitte
unserer gesellschaft dafür sorgen dass
auch diejenigen die es verharmlosen diaz
relativieren die die schreckliche zeit
des nationalsozialismus in deutschland
zum vogelschutz erklären dass die leute
hier in deutschland von uns keine hand
gereicht bekommen die gehören nicht zu
den bürgerlichen parteien die stehen
außerhalb dieses spektrums
außerhalb dieses verfassungs bogens
außerhalb dessen was wir im weitesten
sinne als teil unserer parlamentarisch
politischen ordnung verstehen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass in diesem lande wieder
ein klima entsteht wo so etwas mit der
herabsetzung des politischen gegners mit
der art und weise des umgangs mit der
permanent schärfer werdenden rhetorik
gegen fremde gegen ausländer gegen
zugezogene menschen die in diesem land
hier leben dass das aufhört und ich will
ihnen das klar und deutlich sagen
was da in der letzten woche in hanau
geschehen ist wenn sie die bilder im
fernsehen wieder mütter um ihre männer
oder um ihre söhne trauern
das sind familien vielleicht mit
kurdischen hintergrund vielleicht mit
türkischem hintergrund vielleicht mit
syrischem hintergrund die leben zum teil
in zweiter und dritter generation hier
in deutschland das sind überwiegend
deutsche staatsbürger meine damen und
herren die opfer in der letzten woche
sind landsleute von uns das sind keine
fremden das sind menschen die hier leben
und die opfer in ihren familien beklagen
und deswegen gehört denen unsere
uneingeschränkte und volle solidarität
und unsere unterstützung die grenzen wir
nicht aus die nehmen wir in den arm und
trauern mit ihnen um diese schrecklichen
opfer die es dort in der letzten woche
gegeben hat und auch das muss für
christdemokraten eine völlige
selbstverständlichkeit sein da gibt es
keinen jota unterschied zu allen anderen
menschen die hier in deutschland leben
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und diejenigen die das relativieren
abschwächen
die das in die ecke stellen wollen auch
von ablehnung intoleranz
fremdenfeindlichkeit können niemals
unsere politischen partner werden
niemals und da muss es eine ganz ganz
klare trennung geben es wird niemals die
cdu die hand reichen zur zusammenarbeit
in den parlamenten in den landtagen im
deutschen bundestag im europäischen
parlament
wir müssen dafür sorgen und das ist mit
auch unsere aufgabe dass diese
gruppierungen nicht stark und stärker
werden sondern dass wir durch unsere
politik dafür sorgen dass sie klein und
kleiner werden und dass sie nicht mehr
diese bedeutung haben wie sie gerade
hier in thüringen durch die letzte
landtagswahl bekommen haben es darf nie
wieder passieren dass eine solche
situation wie vom 27 oktober 2009 10 in
einem deutschen landtag oder gar im
deutschen bundestag entsteht die
demokraten in der politischen mitte in
deutschland müssen dafür sorgen und zwar
alle zusammen dass die ränder von links
und rechts nicht so stark werden dass
dieses land irgendwann und regiert wird
das ist unsere gemeinsame aufgabe meine
damen und herren liebe freundinnen und
freunde
[Applaus]
und während wir uns mit diesen themen zu
recht beschäftigen während sie uns
belasten beschweren dreht sich um uns
drum herum die welt trotzdem weiter
sie bleibt nicht stehen es war dass
niemand auf dieser welt auf deutschland
und deswegen müssen wir sehr genau
hinschauen wo wir heute stehen welche
herausforderungen vor uns stehen und wo
wir in einigen jahren sagen wir in zehn
jahren sein wollen
was werden wir im jahr 2030 wenn wir uns
zum dann 38 aschermittwoch in apolda
sehen
meine damen und herren wenn dann
endgültig die aschermittwoch in apolda
der größte aschermittwoch in ganz
deutschland ist was was werden wir dann
was werden wir dann aus der rückschau
sagen über die zeit heute über das jahr
2020 über unsere politische haltung über
unsere politischen entscheidungen bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass wir in zehn
jahren spätestens verstanden haben was
im augenblick geschieht
wir erleben eine geradezu tektonische
verschiebung der politischen und
ökonomischen machtzentren auf der welt
wir leben nicht mehr in der zeit nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg
wir leben nicht mehr in der zweiten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wir leben in der ersten hälfte des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts und diese
zeit wird völlig anders verlaufen als
die letzte hälfte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
wir wissen nicht genau wie die zeit
aussehen wird aber wir können heute
schon absehen dass die alten
institutionen die mal nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg wesentlich geprägt durch die
amerikaner die dritten die franzosen
auch durch russland oder die damalige
sowjetunion
dass diese strukturen die sich da
entwickelt haben
mehr und mehr an bedeutung verlieren
amerika wählt wahrscheinlich in diesem
jahr
donald trump erneut zum präsidenten
ja meine damen und herren es kann sein
dass die demokraten noch eine letzte
chance haben diese wahl zu gewinnen und
gehört für mich zu den besonderheiten
dieses gegenwärtigen amerikanischen
vorwahlkampfes dass die jugend amerikas
in der demokratischen partei einem 78
jährigen zu füßen liegt eine
erstaunliche entwicklung die da
stattfindet ich sag mal in klammern
hinzu der mann ist 15 jahre älter und
einen herzinfarkt älter als ich also
alter allein ist es offensichtlich nicht
was die jugend begeistert und trotzdem
wird gar nichts denn das wahrscheinlich
keine chance haben gegen die gut geölte
maschine dieses amerikanischen
präsidenten donald trump anzustehen und
wahlen zu gewinnen vielleicht noch
jemand anders nicht also richten wir uns
mal darauf ein dass dieser mann
wiedergewählt wird
der wird dann noch selbstbewusster
auftreten und noch stärker sagen america
first und noch weniger rücksicht nehmen
auf die europäer und auf andere in der
welt und wird nur versuchen weiter deals
zu machen und dann sehen wir viele ein
land das in langen historischen linien
denken kann
die eigenschaft fehlt uns häufig wir
denken sehr kurzfristig dieses land und
seine politische führung denkt in langen
historischen linien und vor genau 200
jahren im jahr 1820 war china von seiner
wirtschaftsleistung her stärker als
amerika europa und japan zu sammeln
das ist der referenzwert das ist die
orientierung der jetzigen chinesischen
staatsführung die 200 jahre dazwischen
die empfinden die so als eine art unfall
der welt geschieht
kurz mal entgleist ein bisschen was
schief gegangen aber jetzt knüpfen sie
wieder an das was sie schon einmal waren
nämlich die große führende
industrienationen der welt
und dann setzen sie so ein projekt auf
die das projekt leiden straßen
ich weiß nicht ob sie sich damit mal
etwas intensiver beschäftigt haben die
geben 900 millionen us dollar kredite
und finanzierungshilfen für dieses
projekt fast eine milliarde die
beteiligen 65 länder an diesem projekt
mit denen sie verträge machen
einmal im norden über den landweg einmal
im süden über den seeweg und beide
steilen dieser seitenstraße der landweg
und der see wie ich enden beide im
duisburger hafen ja meine damen und
herren das ist ein globales projekt dass
diese staatsführung da jetzt auf den weg
gebracht hat mit einer ungeheuren
finanziellen kraft und mit einem
gewaltigen politischen machtanspruch
china hat eine europa strategie aber hat
europa auch eine china-strategie haben
wir eine china-strategie in deutschland
ich sage ihnen das alles damit uns klar
ist wir dürfen nicht ständig um und
selbst kreisen und glauben dass dieses
deutschland der nabel der welt ist das
zentrum des globus
nein meine damen und herren darum herum
drum herum verändert sich die welt in
einem rasanten tempo und deswegen finde
ich dass wir eine breite diskussion in
deutschland führen müssen
über die frage wo wir denn in zehn
jahren stehen wollen was denn die
voraussetzungen dafür sind dass wir
schritt halten können mit der
ökonomischen der politischen der
ökologischen entwicklung auf dieser welt
ich habe großen respekt davor dass die
junge generation das freundes for future
greta team berg und viele junge leute
sich jetzt engagieren in der
umweltpolitik ich sage das ohne ohne
ironie ich meine das ernst ich finde das
großartig dass da eine junge generation
unterwegs ist sich wirklich zu
engagieren für dieses eine große thema
und ich rate uns ganz dringend darüber
nicht mit leichtfertigkeit hinweg zu
gehen und auch nicht zu meinen es sei so
ein vorübergehendes problem dass man mal
eben löst wir haben ein riesiges ein
fundamentales ökologisches problem der
klimawandel auf dieser welt meine damen
und herren stellt alles in frage die wir
bisher gelebt haben wir sehr arbeiten
wir unsere mobilität aussieht wie unser
wohlstand erzeugt wird wir müssen über
alle diese fragen miteinander reden aber
eines müssen wir auch klar und deutlich
sagen wenn greta thonberg sagt sie es
sei um ihre jugend betrogen worden
dann muss unsere antwort sein nein liebe
greta thunberg du hast die beste jugend
gehabt die es jemals in diesem teil der
welt für eine junge generation gegeben
hat niemals vorher hatte sie eine
bessere chance gegeben für junge
menschen als für deine generation in
diesem teil der welt
aber wenn du dich schon so engagiert
dann komm rein und wir diskutieren
gemeinsam miteinander wie wir dafür
sorgen können dass auch der nächsten
generation in deutschland in europa und
in vielen teilen der welt genauso gut
gehen kann wie es dir heute geht in
deiner jugend und das ist die aufgabe
die wir gemeinsam politisch
wirtschaftlich umweltpolitisch in
deutschland in europa und auf der welt
lösen müssen und dazu muss die
christlich demokratische union einen
beitrag leisten ich sage wir müssen
einen besseren beitrag dazu leisten dass
ökonomie und ökologie umwelt und
wirtschaft die großen herausforderungen
klimawandel und trotzdem unsere
zivilisation
unsere industriegesellschaft auch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert bestehen
können und dass liebe freundin freunde
können nur wir das können die grünen
nicht was sie von ihrem ganzen
selbstverständnis her sie sind im grunde
genommen bis heute eine linke partei
sie sind keine bürgerliche verteilt sie
sind eine linke partei zu verstehen sie
sich ja auch selbst ja und wenn wir
diese diskussion führen dann müssen wir
damit rechnen dass wir da nicht auf den
uneingeschränkten zuspruch in der
deutschen medienlandschaft stoßen
wiederum alle anwesenden ausgenommen die
sind sehr objektiv und sehr orientiert
daran was sacharbeit und sachen lösungen
sind aber wenn ich mir so anschaue
mit welchen verklärten blicken da der
herr habig und die frau berbalk im
deutschen fernsehen angeschaut werden
also manchmal hat mir das eindruck man
ist bei parship de nicht
wie heißt er wie heißt der schöne
werbespruch und alle 90 sekunden
verliebt sich ein deutscher journalist
in robert habeck
wir haben grosse teile der medien bei
dieser diskussion nicht auf unserer
seite
unsere glaubwürdigkeit in zweifel
gezogen und sie sitzen dann da und
machen vielleicht späßchen
aber wie hatte markus söder heute in
passau gesagt käpt'n iglo
ja glaubt irgendjemand das mit
küchenphilosophie vertrauen zu
beeindrucken ist oder jinping in waging
oder herr horn in ehrfurcht erstarren
wenn das so jemand kommt nein meine
damen und herren wir müssen in diesen
fragen ökonomisch politisch
umweltpolitisch unsere interessen
wahrnehmen aber dann auch sagen welche
herausforderungen wir zu bestehen haben
wenn es etwa darum geht auch
industrieland im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert zu bleiben ganz klar und
deutlich
wenn wir in frage stellen dass
deutschland ein industrieland ist und
bleiben muss und da ganz veränderten
bedingungen mit neuen herausforderungen
antworten wenn wir das in frage stellen
dann werden wir große teile unseres
wohlstands gefährden
und dann werden wir sehen dass die
politischen ränder in deutschland noch
stärker werden und die politische mitte
noch weiter ausgezehrt wird das ist
keine parteipolitische aufgabe allein
das ist eine staatspolitische aufgabe
dafür zu sorgen dass umwelt und
wirtschaft ökonomie und ökologie die
großen herausforderungen des
klimawandels mit der industrie mit neuen
technologien mit den ingenieuren mit den
forscherinnen und forschern die wir in
deutschland haben
gelöst werden und nicht indem man alles
in frage gestellt was heute unseren
wohlstand in diesem lande ausmacht meine
[Applaus]
ist ja fast wie auf dem letzten
bundesparteitag hier so und lassen sie
mich deswegen noch einmal auf die themen
zu sprechen kommen die wir lösen müssen
die cdu der erste punkt ist wir brauchen
in diesem land einen neuen
generationenvertrag
ja es ist gut und richtig dass wir einen
so ausgebauten sozialstaat haben dass
wir viel für die menschen in diesem
lande tun dass wir insbesondere viel für
die älteren tun
aber seien wir ehrlich miteinander die
entscheidungen der letzten jahre und
spreche auch die bundestagskollegen an
auch in dieser großen koalition
die entscheidungen der letzten jahre
waren viel zu häufig entscheidungen die
einseitig zulasten der jungen generation
gegangen sind wir dürfen den jungen
menschen in diesem lande
wir dürfen den jungen menschen in diesem
lande nicht noch höhere lasten auf die
schultern legen wir dürfen die zukunft
dieser jugend nicht infrage stellen
indem wir ihnen ständig weitere
verantwortung übertragen für die lasten
der gegenwart das ist eine aufgabe die
ich schon politisch die ist ethisch die
ist christlich begründet und das muss
die cdu sei ein zweiter
wir müssen wieder die partei ohne jeden
zweifel die partei des rechtsstaats
seien in der bundesrepublik deutschland
[Applaus]
und das heißt dass wir bei aller
toleranz bei aller offenheit bei aller
liberalität bei allem respekt vor
andersdenkenden klare grenzen ziehen
das gilt für natürlich diejenigen die in
diesem lande leben das gilt aber auch
für diejenigen die in dieses land kommen
auf zeit oder auf dauer und auch das
muss klar sein es kann sein dass von
vielen die zu uns kommen eine große
fasziniert ausgeht dass viele zu uns
kommen mit neuen ideen neuen gedanken
großen fähigkeiten aber sie müssen alle
bereit sein ihren beitrag zum sozialen
frieden in diesem lande zu leisten sie
müssen sich an die regeln halten die in
diesem lande gelten meine damen
und der staat unser land die europäische
union muss ihrerseits dafür sorgen dass
die regeln eingehalten werden
ich glaube dass gestern in berlin so
gesagt und wiederhole das heute hier
es darf nie wieder das wort vom
kontrollverlust in deutschland jeden tag
in den medien erscheinen
wir müssen und wir wollen die
europäischen außengrenzen schützen
wir müssen auch in diesem zusammenhang
ein offenes wort vielleicht dieses
besser und sinnvoller wenn wir uns sehr
viel stärker mehr engagieren gegenüber
griechenland gegenüber italien gegenüber
der türkei auch gegenüber syrien wenn es
darum geht die flüchtlinge dort
anständig und einigermaßen
menschenwürdig unterzubringen
wir würden den menschen viel mehr helfen
wenn wir uns stärker engagieren noch
stärker als sie es ohnehin schon tun wir
tun viel aber wir könnten vielleicht
noch mehr tun um diesen menschen die da
in diesen erbarmungswürdigen
flüchtlingslagern zusammengepfercht sind
ein einigermaßen menschenwürdiges leben
zu ermöglichen
aber wenn sie dann meine damen und
herren nach europa kommen wenn sie nach
griechenland kommen auf die insel lesbos
wenn sie nach italien kommen nach
lampedusa
dann ist das nicht ein problem von
griechenland oder ein problem von
italien dann ist das ein gemeinsames
problem von uns allen wir haben viel zu
lange gesagt kümmert ihr euch darum nein
wir müssen uns alle gemeinsam darum
kümmern und dann müssen wir europäische
regeln haben wie wir damit umgehen das
setzt aber voraus dass deutschland nicht
einseitig entscheidungen trifft die
unabgestimmt sind mit den europäischen
partnern und wir dann anschließend sagen
jetzt müsst ihr uns aber alle helfen bei
der lösung dieses problems
andersherum ist die reihenfolge richtig
erst mit den europäischen partnern reden
und dann das problem gemeinsam lösen und
nicht erst das problem entstehen lassen
und dann sagen jetzt müssen uns andere
behilflich sein so funktioniert europa
nicht viel in diesem zusammenhang ein
offenes wort ansprechen was gerade hier
in der region ein problem ausmacht
deutschland macht eine energiewende die
seinesgleichen sucht auf der welt ich
habe dazu meine meinung man kann eine
gute meiner meinung eine andere haben
dies auch in ordnung
aber europa fähig ist das was wir da
gegenwärtig machen nicht es gibt kein
einziges land auf der welt kein einziges
land in europäischen union
das gleichzeitig aus der kernenergie
gleichzeitig aus der steinkohle
verstromung und gleichzeitig aus der
braunkohleverstromung aussteigt wir
müssen die frage beantworten und wenn
ich sage wir meine ich wir die
christlich-demokratische union wo sollen
denn eigentlich der strom herkommen für
die transformation unserer
volkswirtschaft in die co2 neutrale ca
das geht so nicht ich gebe ihnen ein
beispiel
alleine die transformation der deutschen
chemischen industrie und das ist eine
der wichtigsten industrie- bereiche die
wir in deutschland gott sei dank noch
haben allein die transformation der
chemischen industrie in die co2
neutralität bis zum jahr 2050 wird in
diesem zeitpunkt einen strombedarf
auslösen der ist größer als der
strombedarf der gesamten deutschen
industrie zusammen
wir müssen die frage beantworten wo der
strom denn herkommen soll
für diese transformation wenn wir
ernsthaft industrie und chemische
industrie und andere industrien noch in
deutschland behalten wollen das geht so
wie wir es gegenwärtig konzipiert haben
nicht und das muss man auch sagen zu
einem zeitpunkt wo man es wahrscheinlich
noch korrigieren
meine damen und herren wir müssen
unseren arbeitsmarkt fit machen für das
21 jahrhundert
wir müssen der jungen generation
perspektiven geben auch in neuen berufen
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass dieser
arbeitsmarkt schritt hält mit der
technologischen entwicklung in vielen
anderen bereichen der welt
ich spreche nur ein thema an die
digitalisierung unseres landes liegt
jahre hinter dem zurück was eigentlich
sein müsste
das merken sie ja nicht nur bei ihren
handys das merken sie auf ihren rechnern
in jedem betrieb das merken sie in jedem
pc den sie bearbeiten
nur vier prozent der daten mit denen wir
jeden tag umgehen liegen auf deutschen
rechnern oder europäischen rechnern 96
prozent der daten die wir jeden tag
verwenden liegen auf amerikanischen oder
auf chinesischen rechnern wir sind
mittlerweile viel zu abhängig geworden
von amerikanischen tech unternehmen und
mehr und mehr auch von chinesischen tech
unternehmen europa muss ein stück
souveränität in der digitalwirtschaft
zurückgewinnen
das erfordert dass wir dafür geld
einsetzen dass erfordert dass wir
prioritäten ordnen nicht in die alten
industrien sondern in die neuen
industrien
das erfordert dass wir nicht nur
lizenzeinnahmen haben dass er wunderbar
dass die großen unternehmen in
deutschland jetzt über sechs milliarden
euro lizenzgebühren für die 5g lizenzen
bezahlen
aber neben den lizenzgebühren die an in
den bundeshaushalt fließen sollen die
auch gleichzeitig noch die netze
ausbauen woran liegt das eigentlich dass
viele länder in europa dies besser
gemacht haben als deutschland
wir müssten eigentlich führend sein in
der digitalen infrastruktur wir fallen
immer weiter zurück und liegen
mittlerweile auf einem der letzten
europäischen plätze
das kann nicht so bleiben wir müssen
hier modernisieren und zwar sehr sehr
schnell damit deutschland schritt hält
im digitalen zeitalter
das muss unser anspruch sein an uns
wir müssen vieles von dem was ich hier
an spreche zusammen mit europa machen
das geht nicht alleine
deutschland ist nicht allein auf der
welt ja wir sind ein großes land wir
sind mit 82 millionen einwohnern das
bevölkerungsreichste land der
europäischen union aber trotzdem nur 0,8
prozent der weltbevölkerung mit den
anderen europäern zusammen könnten wir
sehr viel stärker sehr viel machtvoller
sein wir könnten sehr viel mehr
erreichen und deswegen auch hier ein
klares wort bei aller kritik an dem was
in europa an der einen oder anderen
stelle nicht so richtig gut läuft und
ich war selber im europäischen parlament
ich weiß wie mühsam das ist und wie
schwierig das ist mit so vielen
mitgliedstaaten dieser europäischen
union zu recht zu kommen aber wir müssen
wege finden wie wir mit europa zusammen
das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert gehen
wenn wir das ganz alleine versuchen
meine damen und herren liebe freunde
dann geht das schief die cdu muss auch
die europapartei in deutschland bleiben
und wir dürfen nie einen zweifel daran
lassen dass wir diesen weg zusammen
gehen wollen mit unseren europäischen
nachbarn in austin west und nord und süd
in dieser europäischen union und
erlauben sie mir erlauben sie mir dass
ich in dem zusammenhang hier auch ein
ein wort zu russland sagen
russland macht es uns im augenblick sehr
sehr schwer und der russische
staatspräsident wladimir putin tut sehr
wenig um es vorsichtig zu sagen
um einen ausgleich wieder mit europa zu
finden aber gerade wie aus deutscher
sicht heraus müssen sagen ohne russland
oder gar gegen russland wird es auf
dauer keine politische stabilität in
europa geben und daher sollten wir alle
versuche unternehmen so schwierig das
ist so schwierig das ist mit russland
irgendwann vielleicht erst nach putin
aber doch wieder wege zu finden wie wir
hier zu einem besseren ausgleich und zu
einem besseren miteinander kommen können
große teile russlands gehören
geografisch und politisch zu europa
und wir dürfen es nicht zulassen dass
china und russland sich gegen europa
verbünden deutschland und europa müssen
auf russland zu gehen und jeden weg
versuchen um daraus wieder mehr
gemeinsamkeiten im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert auch werden zu lassen und
sehen sie diese herausforderungen die
stehen uns bevor in unserem land zu
einer zeit wo das land aufgewühlt ist
diskussionen führt streitet und wo auch
die cdu und ich sage das wirklich hier
offen und ehrlich mit bedauern wieder um
eine neue parteiführung ringt ich habe
mir das gut überlegt in den letzten
tagen und ich habe mich entschlossen
gestern auch öffentlich bekannt zu geben
dass ich mich erneut um den vorsitz der
christlich demokratischen union in
deutschland
[Applaus]
ich freue mich über ihre große
zustimmung
und das ist für mich eine ermutigung und
eine ermunterung diesen weg jetzt zu
gehen
ich weiß was das bedeutet die ersten
kleinen ereignisse sind schon da
und manche geschichte in den medien
meine damen und herren ist halb wahr und
halten war und manchmal ist die halbe
wahrheit
schlimmer als die ganze unwahrheit
deswegen noch einmal wir müssen in
dieser christlich demokratischen union
einen gemeinsamen weg finden ihn
allerdings persönlich davon überzeugt
dass es richtig und notwendig ist dass
wir uns auch wieder öffnen
auch nichtwählerinnen und nichtwähler
zurückgewinnen will er die andere
parteien in deutschland gewählt haben
und es kann nicht so bleiben wie es
heute ist
wenn wir bei 38 prozent legen wenn wir
bei 40 prozent legen denn die bei 41
prozent legen wie bei der bundestagswahl
2013 würde ich sagen okay es gibt viele
gute gründe auf diesem weg weiterzugehen
aber wir liegen wenn wir die csu
herausrechnen und ehrlich miteinander
sind gegenwärtig in den umfragen bei 22
prozent
und das ist ein wert der spätestens zu
diesem zeitpunkt anlass ist nachzudenken
über unseren kurs nachzudenken über
unseren weiteren weg und nachzudenken
über unsere positionierung und deswegen
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle hier
ein klares wort sagen zur politischen
mitte ich möchte dass wir den
politischen streit in diesem land
zurückholen in die politische mitte und
ihn nicht den rändern in deutschland
überlassen wir müssen wieder streit
fähig werden in der politischen mitte
und dass das geht dass das geht meine
damen und herren haben am letzten
wochenende die hamburger gezeigt haben
in hamburg für die cdu ein
katastrophales wahlergebnis eingefahren
aber da hat es zwei andere parteien
gegeben die sich mit interessanten
spitzenkandidaten interessanten themen
strategischen allianzen und positionen
genau um diese mehrheit in der
bevölkerung gerungen haben die
miteinander angetreten sind mit
charismatischen führungspersönlichkeiten
und was ist dabei herausgekommen
dabei ist herausgekommen ein intensiver
wettbewerb in der politischen mitte hoch
interessante debatten im fernsehen und
in der öffentlichkeit wahlergebnisse die
sich für beide beteiligten sehen lassen
können vor allen dingen für die
sozialdemokraten übrigens fußnote auch
deshalb so gut weil die beiden
vorsitzenden der sozialdemokratischen
partei deutschlands ausdrücklich gebeten
worden sind nicht in diesem wahlkampf zu
kommen
[Applaus]
also selbst selbst eine solche
stimmungskanone wie saskia esken war für
den kühlen norden etwas zu viel
wir haben ausdrücklich darum gebeten
nicht zu kommen und das zweite ergebnis
ist die linken und die rechten haben so
gut wie keine rolle gespielt in diesem
wahlkampf so und das muss uns gelingen
bei der nächsten bundestagswahl
wir müssen es schaffen mit den
sozialdemokraten und den grünen um den
richtigen weg in deutschland wieder zu
ringen auch mit der fdp wenn sie denn
dann noch dabei ist ja ich meine damen
und herren ich will das ja auch sagen
das bedaure ich etwas
ich habe dem christian lind noch schon
vor drei jahren gesagt ihr habt nur dann
eine chance zu überleben wenn er
entweder in der regierungszeit oder
stärkste oppositionsfraktion
jetzt sind sie beides nicht ist nicht
gut für die fdp die fdp muss ihr eigenes
profil haben
die fdp muss selbst begründen warum es
eine solche partei in deutschland geben
muss ich wünschte mir dass sie stärker
wären aber mehr können wir nun auch
nicht den rest müssen sie selber machen
sie müssen schon selber dafür sorgen
dass sie sich für unverzichtbar machen
für jedenfalls einen teil der
wählerinnen und wähler in deutschland
wir zerbrechen uns zunächst mal unseren
eigenen kopf und unseren eigenen kopf zu
zerbrechen heißt nicht maß zu nehmen
anderen sondern unseren eigenen kopf zu
zerbrechen heißt selber stark genug zu
sein dass eine mehrheit gegen war es
eine relative mehrheit der deutschen
wählerinnen und wähler sagt ja dieser
partei wollen wir die zukunft
deutschlands anvertrauen
wir müssen antworten geben auf die
großen fragen unserer zeit wir dürfen
nicht im zorn zurück blicken doch werde
ich sicher nicht tun
meine damen und herren die letzten 15 16
jahre in deutschland waren doch im
wesentlichen gute jahre sagen was doch
so wie es im jahr 2020 geht es diesem
land so gut wie es
nie zuvor in der geschichte nach der
wiedervereinigung gegeben gegangen nicht
nie zuvor und das verdienen das
verdanken wir natürlich auch der
bundesregierung das verdanken wir auch
angela merkel der bundeskanzlerin mit
allem respekt bin längst die in allen
themen mit ihrer einer meinung aber dank
zu sagen für das was war ist doch
selbstverständlich für dieses lange
engagement für deutschland und für die
christlich-demokratische union aber
jetzt müssen wir den blick nach vorne
richten und müssen dafür sorgen dass die
antworten neu gegeben werden ja dass
auch in der einen oder anderen stelle
korrekturen vorgenommen werden
ich habe das gestern berlin gesagt
wiederhole es hier die alternative ist
weiter so oder aufbruch und erneuerung
wir brauchen jetzt aufbruch und
erneuerung in deutschland
und dann müssen wir diese begeisterung
die uns heute abend hier trägt sie
müssen wir raus tragen nach deutschland
wir müssen diskutieren lernen wieder mit
den menschen in diesem lande
wir müssen offenen meinungsstreit
aushalten wir müssen in der lage sein
unsere positionen klar und deutlich zu
machen wir müssen es nicht jedem recht
machen in deutschland wir müssen nicht
asymmetrische demobilisierung machen ja
nicht nur die eigenen leute erreichen
und den gegner chloroform ihren nein das
ist nicht unsere aufgabe wir müssen eine
lebhafte offene streitige politische
debatte in diesem lande führen
wir müssen unseren standpunkt dabei
einnehmen und klar und deutlich sagen
was wir für deutschland und für die
europäische union in den nächsten zehn
jahren für richtig halten
und wenn wir das machen habe ich
überhaupt kein zweifel dann werden die
die große politische volkspartei der
mitte bleiben die wir in den 70 jahren
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland immer gewesen sind das
schaffen wir das können wir schaffen
aber meine damen und herren das schafft
auch nicht einer allein sowohl völlig
klar ja ich bewerbe mich um den vorsitz
der christlich demokratischen union aber
dazu gehören anderen natürlich auch wir
brauchen eine große mannschaft und wir
brauchen ein team und wenn die wahl so
ausgeht wie ich sie mir vorstelle am 25
april 2020 in berlin gehören armin
laschet und jens spahn natürlich zu
meinem team dann sind wir eine
mannschaft dann gehen jetzt zusammen
dann geht es zusammen nach vorn
und deswegen lassen nämlich zum schluss
sagen ich spiele den ball zu ihnen
zurück wir brauchen aktive unterstützung
wir brauchen die abgeordneten in den
parlamenten
wir brauchen die kommunalpolitiker aber
wir brauchen auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger wir brauchen junge menschen die
sich für die cdu engagieren
wir brauchen neue mitglieder die bereit
sind sich zur cdu zu bekennen
wir brauchen wirklich ist bekennt thum
für die christlich-demokratische union
und deswegen sage ich ihnen raus aus der
komfortzone rein in die politische
debatte in unserem land und mit uns
mitgehen in einen bundestagswahlkampf 20
21 der die weichen stellt für den
nächsten 4 jahre und sicher auch darüber
hinaus für deutschland und für europa
und wenn wir dafür gemeinsam einstehen
wenn wir diesen weg gemeinsam gehen dann
lohnt sich jede anstrengung dann lohnt
sich jeder konflikt dann bin ich bereits
jede kritik auch auszuhalten die wo
immer alle anwesenden wieder
rausgenommen an mir und anderen geübt
wird ich bin alles bereit auszuhalten
aber diesen weg den müssen wir gemeinsam
gehen die haben es der partei aber wir
haben es insbesondere dem land sind wir
es schuldig dass wir einen solchen weg
miteinander gehen und dass wir auch in
zehn jahren wenn wir im jahr 20 30 hier
in apolda wieder zurück gehen und sagen
können aus der rückschau es hat sich
gelohnt es war ein hartes stück arbeit
aber wir sind unserer verpflichtung
nachgekommen wir haben unsere arbeit
gemacht haben unseren job getan und wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass dieses land
auch im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
eine gute zukunft hat und daran müssen
sie alle die sie hier sitzen meine damen
und herren mitwirken damit dieses große
projekt gelingen kann herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]